[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
جميع
السعوديه والصين توفقان العلاقات بشراكه
استراتيجيه شامله وخطه مواء ما بين رؤيه
20 30
ومبادره الحزام والطريق
الورد
اكبر من المتخيل عشرات المشتبه بهم خط طول
لاعدام المستشار وتشكيل جيش جديده
تتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
بوتين وضع يده على شركات كبرى لضمان تمويل
عجله الحرب لكن هجره العقول وشح الواردات
عرقله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من الرياض حيث وقع
العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان مع الرئيس
الصيني تشييجي بينج اتفاقيه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين هذا
واستعرض الملك سلمان مع الرئيس الصيني
بحضور ولي العهد حلقه الصداقه التاريخيه
بين البلدين وسبل تعزيزها في شتى المجلات
كما شهد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس الصيني على توقيع عدد من
اتفاقيات التعاون او مذكرات التفاهم ومن
بينها خطه الموازمه بين رؤيه المملكه
2030 ومبادره الحزام والطريق كما وقع
البلدان على مذكره تفاهم في مجال الطاقه
الهيدروجينيه والتشجيع الاستثمار المباشر
وشملت الاتفاقيات الموقعه كذلك مذكره
تعاون في مجال الاسكان واخرى خاصه بتعلم
اللغه الصينيه
[موسيقى]
وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان قد عقد جلسه مباحثات مع رئيس
الصينيه في قصر اليمامه بالرياض واعرب ولي
العهد السعودي في بدء المحادثات عن ترحيبه
بزياره الرئيس الصيني الى المملكه شدد على
ان الشراكه السعوديه
تسهم في حفظ السلم والامن الدوليين مؤكدا
العمل على دفع الشراكه بين البلدين الى
مستويات الاعلى
تبتسم العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه بالصداقه
والثقه متبادله فخامه الرئيس
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه والصين وحرص
على ترسيخ جميع الامكانيات الدفع بتلك
الشراكه لمستويات اعلى تقدم مصالح مشتركه
في الحفاظ السلم والامن الدوليين ونحن على
ثقه نتائج الايجابيه لهذا اللقاء ستنعكس
بشكل كبير جدا
بان السعوديه ستكون في قائمه مقاصد
السائحين الصينيين في الخارج واكد الرئيس
الصيني ازمه بكين على توسيع التبادلات
الثقافيه والشعبيه مع السعوديه
وقبل ذلك كان الرئيس الصيني اكد ان
الزياره ستفتح عصرا جديدا لعلاقات بلاده
مع المملكه والعالم العربي شدد اعلى
مواصله الجهود للارتقاء بعلاقات الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين الصين والسعوديه
الى مستوى اعلى وزياده الموامه بين مبادره
الحزام والطريق ورؤيه 2030 واضاف الرئيس
الصيني ان الزياره تكرس تضامن المجتمع
الصيني والعربي لبناء المستقبل المشترك
نحو عصر جديد لافتا الى اقامه الصين
علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله مع
اثنتي عشره دوله عربيه وتحقيقهم انجازات
وصفها بالايقونيه والخارقه فيشه المجلات
هذا واكد جيمنج المضيق قدما لبناء علاقات
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الصينيه الخليجيه
التي تشهد تطورا سليما ومستقرا ووافق
تعبير
من جانبه اعلن وزير الاستثمار السعودي
خالد بن عبد العزيز الفالح توقيع خمس
وثلاثين اتفاقيه مع الصين واضاف ان
الاتفاقيات الموقعه بين مؤسسات سعوديه
والصينيه شملت قطاعات عده بينها الطاقه
والتعدين والنقل وسلاسل الامداد كما تضمنت
قطاعات الخدمات اللوجستيه وتصنيع المركبات
والرعايه الطبيه وتقنيه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
حول هذه القمه السعوديه الصينيه
والاتفاقيات التي وقعت ينضم الينا من
الرياض الدكتور فهد بن جمعه عضو مجلس
الشورى السعودي سابقا ومن القاهره ايضا
الدكتور حسن ابو طالب مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم
الكريمين
بلدين الى شراكه استراتيجيه شامله
ما الذي يفتحه هذا العنوان من افاق
للتعاون بين الدولتين
اولا مساء الخير عليك وعلى جميع المشاهدين
الكرام نعم هذه
الزياره انا اعتبرها زياره تاريخيه لانها
جاءت في اوقات صعبه يعاني منها العالم من
انكماش النت اقتصادي ومن مشاكل جيو سياسيه
ولتوب خرج الاقتصاد العالمي من اثار
الجائحه فهذه العلاقه هي تنظر الى المدى
الطويل ماذا سوف تحقق هذه العلاقات
والاتفاقيات على المدى الطويل وبشر بشكل
اقتصاد النمو في السنوات الماضيه كان انه
يصل الى 10% ثم انحدر الى الان يصل الى 5%
فهي تبحث عن اسواق ذات النمو قوي تستطيع
ان تسوق منتجات وان تستثمر في الفرص همم
ده تنميه النسبيه في الخليج وفي البلدان
العربيه فهذا الوقت هو يجعلها فعلا زياره
تاريخيه الى قطروف الحاليه هي طروف تتعلق
بالاقتصاد هناك حظر على همم
نفط الروسي هناك سقف سعري للنفط الروسي في
اليات السوق فالوقت مناسب ان يكون هناك
تنوع في العلاقات الدوليه ليكون ال- ال-
يسود الامن والاستقرار في الحقيقه ايضا
ينعكس ايجابيا على الاقتصاد العالم دكتور
حسن يعني منذ قليل بخبر عاجل رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني رئيس الصين وعد ببحث في
قضيه ديون الصين على السودان هو خبر مهم
جدا ولكن
المستوى العربي شرك استراتيجيه شامله اذا
بين فضيه والصين ولكن اا بما يخص الدول
العربيه هل سنرى همم هذا المستوى من
الشركات بين الصين والدول العربيه والصين
ودول الخليج شبيهه بالتي حصلت مع السعوديه
وباستاده المشاهدين هذا سؤال يجعلنا ننظر
للعلاقات العربيه الصينيه من منظور شامل
الاتفاقات الاستراتيجيه الصينيه العربيه
الشامله وقعت ما عدد كبير ايضا من الدول
العربيه في غدون الثلاث سنوات الماضيه
حوالي 12 بلد عربي وقع مثل هذه الاتفاقيات
لكن جاءت جاءت كرونه وايضا ال- همم يعني
الاحداث والتداعيات الخطيره التي حدثت
ايضا منذ مطلع هذا العام ما يتعلق بحلب
اوكرانيا وتدعتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه
عالميا
اثاره الى حد ما في ما يتعلق بتطبيق جوانب
كثيره من هذه الاتفاقيات هذه الاتفاقيات
الشراكه الشامله ليست فقط تتعلق بالشق
التجاري وانما تتعلق ايضا بتبادل المنافع
في اكثر من مجال وايضا التركيز على الجزء
الثقافي والجزء السياحي والجزء المعرفي
والجزء الذي يتعلق به ان يهنئ ان يكون
هناك ليه تثبيت قاعده ان النظام الدولي هو
نظام تعددي يسمح بالتفاعل طيب والسلمي بين
كل الاطراف وبدون ان يتدخل احد الاطراف في
الشان الداخلي للاطراف الاخرى بالتالي
فهذا هذه الفلسفه هي الفلسفه صينيه عربيه
مشتركه لان العالم الارض العربي ايضا
بيؤمن باهميه تعدد العلاقات وايضا يؤمن به
ان لا يكون طرفا في استقطاب مع احد
الاطراف ضد الاطراف الاخرى وهو ما تريد
بعض الدول الكبرى في صراعتها مع الاخرين
العالم العربي من مصلحه ان يكون هناك يعني
ما يمكن ان نسميه بسياسات متوازنه مع كل
الاطراف قصين هنا تلعب دورا مهما جدا جدا
في تاكيد وتوثيق هذه القاعده
العزيزين اتمنى بقائكما
مشاهدينا خلال ثلاثه عقود اتخذت الصين
مكانتها كاحدى اكبر القوى الاقتصاديه
بالعالم بل فانيها تحديدا الصين طبقت
سياسه التعلم من اخطائها الكثيره حينها
لتصبح تجربتها مثالا قابلا للاسقاط على
بعض الاقتصادات المنهجه في دول تملك
الموارد
دائره الفقر ومستنقع الحروب اللذان حاصر
التنين الصيني للسنوات اخرجه اكثر شراسه
ووضعه بمصاف الاقتصادات الاولى عالميا
والسبيل لذلك وفق دراساتنا سياسه التعلم
من الاخطاء فالصين تملصت من براثن مجاعه
لتتحول خلال ثلاثه عقود فقط الى ثاني اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم بعد معالجتها لثلاثه
اخطاء
اولها الوثبه العظيمه التي كان يرجى منها
تحويل البلاد من الزراعه الى التصنيعه
لكنها تسببت بمجاعه راحه ضحيتها الملايين
وفي خمسينيات القرن الماضي اما الخطا
الثاني الذي ارتكبه الزعيم الصيني فكان
الثوره الثقافيه بهدف التخلص من معارضه في
الحزب الشيوعيه ثوره اوصلت الولاده لحافه
الانهيار وتسببت بتراجع الدخل الفرديه الى
اقل من 200 دولار سنويا
فيما ثالث الاخطاء يتمثل بالحروب ثلاث
مواجهات مسلحه محدوده زمنيا ومكنيا بين
عام 62 و 79 استنزفت قدرات البلاد
الاقتصاديه وانهجتها هذه الاخطاء علمت
القاده الجدد عدم تطوير الاقتصاد عبر
الصدمات بل اتمامه تدريجيا ليعتده الشعب
ثم تطبيق سياسه الانفتاح على الاستثمار
الاجنبي والقطاع الخاص وتبني النظام
الاقتصاديه الراسمالي في مفارقه غريبه
لبلد شيوعيه وبعد ان كان نصيبها من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لا يتجاوز واحدا فاصل
ثمانيه في المئه عام
حققت قفزه النوعيه مع ارتفاع هذا الرقم
الى 16% عام 2020 اي ان اقتصادها تضاعف
نحو تسع مرات خلال اقل من سبعه عقود كما
اصبح القطاع الخاص يساهم بن 60% من
الاقتصاد الصيني
ورغم ان تجربه الصينيه غير قابله للاسقاط
بحذافيرها على اقتصادات منهكه لبعض الدول
العربيه بسبب اختلاف بعدد السكان والمساحه
والموارد الطبيعيه لكنها اكثر قابليه
للتطبيق في بعض الدول خاصه تلك التي تجمع
بين الموارد الطبيعيه والبشريه والاستقرار
السياسيه وتستطيع البدء في السير في طريق
التنميه
جديد اعود لكما ضيفيه دكتور فهد من الرياض
وايضا دكتور حسن من القاهره الدكتور فهد
يعني خطه بين رؤيه 20 30 ومبادره الحزام
والطريق كيف يمكن ان تفيد همم الواحده
الاخرى
اولا مثل ما ذكرت تنميه الاقتصاد ليس من
خلال الصدمات وانما لمواجهه الصدمات هذا
هو التخطيط والاستراتيجي اييي الهام نعم
الملائمه هي تتجلى في
استغلال البيز النسبيه
وتنميه الاستثمارات وتعزيزها هناك
استثمارات كبيره للسعوديه سواء في الصين
او في دول اخرى وايضا من الصين
الاستثمارات كبيره داخل المملكه
هو احد اهم مكونات الجي تي دي بي او
الناتج المحلي الاثنين مالك وهذا الملائمه
هي كيف نستغل النسبيه وكيف نعزز التجاره
والتدفق الاستثمارات المباشره بين همم
الصين والسعوديه ودول الخليج والدول
العربيه هذا هو المغزى من كل هذه السياسات
اقتصاديه والملائمه ان يكون هناك نمو
اقتصادي واقتصاد متنوع يواجه الصدمات
ويكون وتكون التنميه تنميه مستدامه وان
الدول مثل السعوديه التي تتطلع الى ان
تكون ضمن اكبر 10 اقتصاديات في العالم
فالمملكه من خلال رؤيتها 20 30 هي تنظر
الى الفرص
وتستمر فيها
وتستغلها وهكذا همم جاءت هذه الزياره همم
له تعزيز الاستثمارات والتبادل التجاري
واستغلال الفرص واستخدام التقنيه وكما
تعلمين
الاقتصاديات العالميه مثلا امريكا وغيرها
الخدمات هي تمثل
يا 60 ل 70% من اي اقتصاد في العالم ولذا
التركيز على السياحه على الترفيه على
الخدمات اللوجستيه وغيرها هي
القطاعات التي سوف تدعم النمو الاقتصادي
في المدى المتوسط والطويل
تحول الى الدكتور حسن يعني اودا اسالك عن
رايك باكثر الدول جاهزيه
لاسقاط او الاستفاده من التجربه الصينيه
الاقتصاديه ما من الدول العربيه لديها
الجاهزيه للاستفاده من هذه التجربه
ايه يعني دعيني اقول ان التجربه الصينيه
هي تجربه شامله متعدده ولها جوانب خاصه
للغايه
بعيده الصله عن الجوانب المنتشره في
العالم العربي وبالتالي الذي لابد ان نضع
في الاعتبار مثلا على سبيل المثال الضوء
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني ايضا التجربه
الاستفاده من الاخطاء التاريخيه الكبرى
التي يعني انهكت الصين يعني
بعد ثلاث او اربع سنوات منذ بدء سياسه
الانفتاح الاقتصادي منذ عام
1878 وكان في هذه المرحله الاقتصاد الصيني
في مرحله بائسه للغايه هنا تم التركيز على
نوعين من ال- من الامور الامر الاول هو
التعليم والتدريب الفني في المدارس
واشعتها في كافه المناطق والاستفاده من
هؤلاء المتدربين والمتعلمين الفنيا في
الصناعات الحديثه التي حاولت الصين في ذلك
الوقت المبكر الان تتبناها باعتبارها هي
الاساس الذي تبنى عليه
الاقتصاد الصيني الصناعي الذي يواكب ما
يمكن ان نسميه من متطلبات العصر مثل هذه
الامور يعني نادره الحدوث في العديد من
البلدان العربيه لكن دعيني اقول ان كثير
من البلدان العربيه لديها الموارد
الطبيعيه التي يمكن ايضا في سياقه تنموي
شامل كما هو حادث الان في كثير من الدول
العربيه يمكن ان تحقق النقلات التي تقع
نعم دكتور حسن دكتور فهد
اطرح عليكما سؤال مشترك همم
باطلاع على التقرير لوكاله بلوم بلوم
العالميه
لشهر اكتوبر من عام 2022 تحديدا حجم
التبادل او الورد الصيني من النفط العربي
هو
57.4 مليون برميل من السعوديه فقط لها
العراق ب 55 مليون ثم الامارات والكويت
وما الى ذلك همم باب الطاقه هل سيبقى هو
بين الصين والدول العربيه ام هناك مجال
لابواب اخرى يمكن العمل عليها تفضل دكتور
فهد بدايه
في مزيج الطاقه للعقود القادم ولكن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول الخليج
والعربيه كلها تسعى الى التحول الى الطاقه
المتجدده والمحافظه على البيئه
والصيد هي اكبر منتج للطاقه المتجدده في
العالم همم انتاجها تتجاوز 1000 همم كيكه
ومصدر اساسي للصين ولل الانتهاء المواد
البتروكيماويه
ولكن ايضا
تحول المتامي همم له الطاقه المتجدده سوف
يستغرق فتره طويله الى عام 2000 و50 او ما
بعد ذلك سوف يبقى عنصر اساسي في الطاقه
دكتور حسن
بالتاكيد الطاقه سوف تظل عنصر مهم جدا في
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه وخصوصا العلاقات
الخليجيه الصينيه لكن دعيني اقول ان الامر
الان بيتجاوز فكره التركيز على الطاقه الى
جوانب الاخرى وفي التاكيد الاستثمار
الصناعي المشتركه هذا عامل مهم جدا للغايه
ومفيد للطرفين ايضا فكره سلاسل الامداد
والتعاون فيها ما بين الطرفين نحن قد
استفدنا من جائحه كرونا بان سلاسل سلاسل
الامداد التي تعتمد على طرف واحد واساسي
يمكن ان تصاب بمرض كبير ويمكن ان تعطل
كثير من الجهود المتعلقه بالتجاره الدوليه
وحسن يعني استغلال الموارد وبالتالي هناك
صيغه جديده ايضا يتم البحث فيها ما بين
الصين وما بين العديد من البلدان العربيه
فيما يتعلق به الاستثمار المشترك وسلاسل
الامداد وايضا التصنيع فيما يتعلق
بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه وثائقه التطور هذه
هي امور جديده جدا وايضا تفيد الطرفين
فيما يتعلق بما تسمعه عن العصر الجديد نحن
نستعد جميعا هذا العصر التكنولوجي الجديد
اضافه الى ايضا تبادل المعارف التقنيه
فيما يتعلق بالصناعات العسكريه والصناعات
الامنيه هذا امر مهم للغايه سواء للصين
سواء للجميع الدول العربيه بدون استثناء
وبالتالي فنحن امام رؤيه شامله الطاقه
تلعب فيها جزء مهم ولكن هناك ايضا جوانب
اخرى بتدفع وتكون هي ايضا مهمه لا تقل
اهميه عن
الاستثمار في الطاقه التقليديه او في
الطاقه الحديثه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن
ابو طالب وايضا من الرياض الدكتور فهد بن
جمعه شكرا جزيلا لكم
هذا هو يتوفد القاده العرب للمشاركه في
القمهتين العربيه والخليجيه حيث وصل
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ثم ولي
العهد الكويتيه الشيخ مشعل الاحمد ورئيسه
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهاني والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
والرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ورئيس الرئاسي
الرئيس المجلس رئاسي الليبي محمد المنفي
ورئيس جيبوتي اسماعيل العمري ورئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الخارجيه السعوديه والاماراتيه
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ورئيس
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد
بن زايد لتبادل سجينين بين واشنطن وقد اكد
بيان
سعوديين يعكس علاقات الصداقه
امريكا وروسيا واشار البيان الى ان ابوظبي
استقبلت الامريكيه بريتني جراينر عبر
طائره خاصه قادمه من موسكو وذلك بالتزامن
مع استقبال الروسيه فيكتور عبر طائره خاصه
واوضعها البيان السعودي الاماراتي المشترك
ان عمليه تبادل السجينين بين موسكو واشنطن
تمت عبر مطار ابو ظبي كما اعرب البيان عن
شكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه والامارات
العربيه المتحده
لحكومتي امريكا وروسيا
لتعاونهما لانجاح وسلطه تبادل السجين
اليوم
من المكتب البيضاوي هي امنه وعلمتني
الطائره في طريقها للديار بعد اشهر من
المفاوضات مع الروس التي مرت بظروف صعبه
بلدها وبين محبيها ما كان يجب ان تبقى
هناك لوحدها بريتني طلبت مني الا انساها
وامريكيين اخرين لمساعدتهم على نيل حريتهم
والعوده لاهلهم نجحنا في اطلاق سراح
بريتني ونعمل على اطلاق سراح امريكيين
اخرين
تابعونا معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
صدمه جديده للقصر الملكي انتقادات لتشارد
وويليم واتهامات للصحافه بقياده لعبه قذره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد متى سالوا المانيا
تعيشوا صدمه محاوله الانقلاب المحبطه من
جهات تنتمي لاقصى اليمين لكن الاجهزه
الامنيه لا وقت لديها للصدمه فالاستخبارات
الالمانيه قالت ان مجموعه الريخ المتطرفه
كانت تخطط لعمل خطير في البلاد بينما دعت
وزاره الداخليه لاعاده النظر عن قرب في
المؤسسات الامنيه خاصه وان المخطط كان
اضخم مما يعتقد
في المانيا يبدو ان ما اطل براسه امس هو
فقط راس شبح النازي اما الجذور فاعميقه
على غير المتوقع عمليات الاعتقال التي
انطلقت لتفكيك مجموعه من اقصى اليمين كان
هدفها الانقلاب على الدوله تتواصل تضاعف
عدد من يخدعون للتحقيق ليتخطى 50 في رقم
بعيد عن ان يكون نهائيا لكن اخطر ما في
العمليه تكشفه نيو تايمز مخطط الانقلاب لم
يكن يقتصر فقط على اقتحام مقر البرلمان بل
اغتيال راس الدوله المستشار اولف جولدز مع
عدد من المشرعين الذين تصرفهم المجموعه
الانقلابيه بالاعداء تقرير صحيفه
الامريكيه اشار ايضا الى ان المخطط كان
يهدف الى تخريب شبكه الكهرباء لتسهيل
عمليه الانقلاب وان عناصر المجموعه اشتروا
بالفعل هواتف وتعمل بالاقمار الصناعيه
لضمان بقاء التواصل بينهم خلال مراحل
التنفيذ الانقلاب المزمار
اما الجانب الذي يبعث على الاطمئنان حتى
الان فهو سقوط الراس المدبر الامير هنري
الثالث عشر الذي كان يريد ان ينصب نفسه
رئيسا جديدا للبلاد في حال نجاح الانقلاب
المتهم الرئيسي في القضيه ينحدر من عائله
رئيس الملكيه الالماني ويبلغ من العمر 71
عاما وهو رجل اعمال النشطه في مجال
العقارات ومقيم في مدينه فرانكفورت وسط
المانيا وكان سيتم في حال نجاح الانقلاب
اعلان حكومه جديده في ظل قيادته وتشكيل
جيش الماني جديد
حتى الان من غير الواضح مدى قدره المجموعه
على تنفيذ مخططها لكن الاكيده ان ضخامه
عدد المشتبهم ووجود حديث عن الاتصالات مع
روسيا او غيرها يشيل بان المحاوله لم تكن
له هو وادى النازيه التي يتبرا منها
الالمان منذ عقود لم تموت
وتنضم الينا من برلين مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام اهلا بك معنا راغده يعني
نيورك تايم تتحدث عن ان اولف شوز كان هو
المستهدف والمراد كان اغتيال له هل من
تسريبات او معلومات من الجانب الالماني
حول هذه النقطه بالتحديد من المستهدف
مساء الخير اهلا بك يعني عندما نتحدث
عندما كان الكلام منذ يوم امس على انقلاب
على السلطه السلطه تعني كامل مكوناتها
يعني ليس فقط اعضاء البرلمان ولكن بكامل
مكوناتها من الحكومه ورئيسها بطبيعه الحال
او لا مستشار الالماني وربما رئيس الدوله
ايضا
همم يعني هذا كان المخطط على الاقل ولكن
انتقادات كثيره يعني بدات تظهر اليوم في
اليوم الثاني ل- اا الحديث الاعلان المدعي
العام عن احباط عمليه محاوله انقلاب على
الدوله بانه الكلام على انقلاب او محاوله
انقلاب وهي كلمه مضخه جدا وبينه همم ما
حصل او انه هذه المجموعه كانت بعيده جدا
عن تحقيق هذا الهدف ربما هذا ايضا يدعمه
اعتراف رئيس الاستخبارات الالمانيه كان
يتحدث احدى القنوات الالمانيه ويكون بانه
نحن نراقب هذه المجموعه مدربه الماضي ولم
يكن هناك ابدا خطر بانه هذه الامور تخرج
عن السيطره او نحن انتظرنا حتى نجمع ادله
كافيه على ان هناك اثباتات يمكن ان تكون
مقبوله لدى المحكمه بانها جماعه ارهابيه
لذلك انتظرنا كل هذا الوقت وقال بانه ان
نقطع التي جعلتنا نتحركي عندما بدات هذه
المجموعه تشتري السلاح لذلك لم يكن هناك
بخطر حقيقي الداهم هذه الكلمه ايضا
استخدمها رئيس الاستخبارات الالمانيه
الداخليه ولكنه قال بانه كان خطرا حقيقيا
ولكنه لم يكن داهما بمعنى يعني هذه
المجموعات المجموعات اليمنيه المتطرفه هي
موجوده في المانيا لا احد ينكر وجودها
الاستخبارات الالمانيه اصلا يعني في
ثانويه في تقاريرها تقول بانه اليمن وتطرف
ما زال يشكل اكبر خطر همم يعني على الامن
الداخلي هذه الجماعات يمكن ان تنفذ او
تشكل خطر على افراد ربما كان هناك عمليه
اختيار قبل ثلاث سنوات لسياسي ايضا من قبل
يعني احد النزيين الجدد ولكن ان يكون هناك
خطر على يعني شكل الدوله بشكل عام همم على
الدوله بكامل انظمتها بالفعل هناك
انتقادات الكلام هو مبالغ به همم ويعني لم
يكن ابدا هناك تهديد على يعني ان يكون
هناك انقلاب على النظام بشكل كامل تصريح
لافت راغده لوزيره الداخليه الالمانيه
تحدثت فيها عن ضروره القاء نظره عن قرب
الى المؤسسات الامنيه الى ماذا كانت تلمح
تعلمين بان هذه المجموعه كانت لديها جناح
سياسي وجناح عسكري هذا الجناح العسكري يضم
بشكل اساسي من كانوا ينتمون للجيش
الالماني سابقا منهم من كان ينتمي القوات
المسلحه للقوات الخاصه في الجيش الالماني
بمعنى انهم كانوا مدربين على حمل السلاح
واستخدامه ويعرفون ايضا من اين يمكن شراء
هذه الاسلحه كان هناك عضو واحد حتى في هذه
في هذا الجناح المسلحه العسكري هو ما زال
في القوات الالمانيه الخاصه لذلك هو منذ
فتره منذ سنوات هناك انتقادات للقوات
المسلحه بانه عمليه تصفيه او انتقاء
الافراد الذين ينتمون اليها لا تحصل بشكل
جيد هناك دائما اختراق يعني اليمين
المتطرف لهذه الجماعات فضائح متتاليه تلف
القوات المسلحه منذ سنوات كان هناك تعهد
بان يتم محاربه هذا الامر ولكن على ما
يبدو بانه هذا الامر لم تتم معالجته هنا
كده دعوات ليس فقط من وزيره الداخليه في
الوا انت فايزر لمعالجه هذا الامر ولكن
ايضا من حزب الخضر الذي يريد ان يطرح هذا
الامر داخل البرلمان يفتح نقاش ليعرف ما
هي الخطوات التي اتخذت لمحاربه الامين
المتطرف داخل الجيش همم وما الذي يجب
القيام به هناك ايضا يعني دعوات ان يكون
هناك فعلا همم
فحص اكبر بكثير وادق واعمق لمن ينتمون
للقوات المسلحه حول اتجاه الافكار التي
يحملونها حول ما اذا كانوا يؤمنون بنظريات
المؤامره يعني يحملون افكار متطرفه وما
الى ذلك همم او محاوله غير هذه الافكار
قبل قبولهم همم داخل همم داخل الجيش شكرا
جزيلا لك من برلين مراسله العربيه
[موسيقى]
اذا ازمه هي الاسوا منذ
1993 ليست حرب اوكرانيا شتاء بحد ذاتها
وانما تداعياتها على من شنت تلك العمليه
العسكريه نتحدث عن روسيا تلك الدوله التي
تصنف التاسعه عالميا من حيث عدد السكان
باتت تشكو من قله العماله وسوق التوظيف
قاب قوسين او ادنى من عدم تحقيق اي تقدم
ارجوك هي الحرب دائما هكذا لابد ان تستنزف
الاطراف المتنازعه ليس فقط بالدمار الذي
تشهده مناطق نوصفت في اوكرانيا كم مجزره
بوتشا التي مازالت تبكي اشلاها حتى الان
في روسيا ايضا لابد ان تتحمل ضريبه
عمليتها العسكريه على ارضها كيف ذلك صحيفه
وسط رجل الامريكيه اوضحت ان الرئيس الذي
قتل يحاول ان يشد قبدته على الاقتصاد بشكل
اكبر ببساطه مفتاح تمويل الحرب وضخ
الاموال في شركات تصنيع الاسلحه ومشهبه
دعونا نفكك المقاله لتتضح الصوره اكثر عما
يجري في موسكو تحديدا اعلان التعبئه
الجزئيه قبل ثلاثه اشهر واستدعاء نحو
300000 جندي ما قبل هذا النبا لم يكن
الروس داخل البلاد يفكرون بما يجري خارج
حدود بلادهم او ربما حتى منازلهم الى ان
جاء هذا الخبر كالساعقه على البعض هنا
بدات روسيا تعاني ازمه ديرافيه نزوح جماعي
وحدود مقتضده هاجروا بلادهم لاسيما اولئك
الشباب هربا من ان يجبر على القتال فذهبوا
للبحث عن فرص عمل في بلدان اخرى
حيث يمثل المتخصصون في مجال التكنولوجيا
خمس المجموعه وفقا لشركه هدهد هانتر
المعنيه بالوظائف في روسيا ما يعني ان
تطوير الانتاج المحلي ومصانع الاسلحه لم
يعد سريعا مهما حاول بوتن ان يتكي عليه من
اجل تحقيق اهدافه
[موسيقى]
فحسب وزاره الماليه الروسيه اظهرت
البيانات انا نفقات الدفاع ارتفعت بنحو 30
بالمئه مقارنه بعام 2021 الى حوالي 78
مليار دولار بالتاكيد استمرار الحرب يعني
ان هذه الارقام مرجحه بزياده وما يحول ذلك
ويقود جهود تغذيه الحرب تتدخل فيه ايضا
تلك العقوبات الغربيه كاخر حزمه فرضت
عليها بيعه نفسها الخام للبرميل الواحد
مقابل 60 دولار انا علما بان الاورال
الروسي هو شريان اقتصادي لداخل البلاد
امام ذلك وباعتراف بوتن ببعض اوجه القصور
اوجه القصور قرر ان يجبر بعض الشركات
الخاصه على المشاركه بانتاج معدات للجيش
وان كانت بعيده كل البعد تلك المنتجات لكن
مساعده القوات اصبحت هدفا وطنيا
في مجلس الدومه اوضح الشهر الماضي انهم
يخططون لبناء مصانع جديده كلها تلبي
احتياجات القوات المسلحه وقال ان بوتين
ناقشا مع ايرالفاجون ذا فود وهي اكبر شركه
عالميه لتصنيع الدبابات في تسريع الانتاج
مؤكدا انها اوامر صارمه للدفاع عن روسيا
اما نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي يوريسي
بوريسي فاقر بان الصناعه تواجه مشكله في
القوى العامله في المصنع الذي يعمل فيه
حوالي مليون شخص ويفتقر الى 400,000 اخرين
وشدد المتحدث باسم الكرام لان على ان مجمع
الانتاج العسكري يخضع لاشد اجراءات مكافحه
الفساد صرامه في اي قطاعا من قطاعات
الاقتصاد وقبل سنوات قد اخذ على المنتجات
الصناعيه ذات التقنيات العاليه لسيطره
شركه قابضه كبرى تسمى راسك والتي تصيطر
على اكثر من 800 شركه
اليكم قصه رئيس شركه خاصه لتعلم كيف اشرك
بوتن الشركات الخاصه في هذه الحرب يقول
الكسندر بيردينينقوف مدير العلاقات
التجاريه للملابس لوريس وحقائب الاطفال في
امسك بسايبيريا انه تلقى مكالمه من مكتب
وزاره الدفاع الاقليمي وسالوه اذا ما كان
بامكانه تصميم حقائب ظهر بشكل سريع للقوات
التي يحشدونها فلم يكن رده الا بالاجابه
وبسعر مخفض لان ذلك واجب وطني لم يرغب في
الاستفاده منه ماديا على حد تعبير
دينكوف حديثهم مؤكدا ان 60 خياطا وضعوا
اعمالهم جانبا وعملوا على مدار اثنتي عشر
ساعه بلا اي عطله لينتج سته الاف حقيبه في
غدوني اسبوعين
شركه اخرى للمعدات الطبيه تسمى التكنيكه
اشارت ايضا في او شاركت في المهمه التي
عفوا
اصبحت بنظرهم وطنيه وعلى لسان نائب مدير
الشركه قال في احدى المقابلات الاعلاميه
كالبلدي باسره تغيرت حياتنا لننفذ امر
الدفاع عن الدوله وعباره بعباره ملطفه رغم
الضغط الهائل يجب ان نعمل بجد
[موسيقى]
طارو موضوع
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
ما يتعلق بالوثائق السريه تعود لتطفو على
سطح مجددا الرئيس الامريكي السابق كلف
شركه خاصه بتفتيش اربعه عقارات بعد توجيه
قاد فيدرالي باتجاه البحث بجديه اكبر عن
اي مواد سريه لا تزال في حوز ترامب
التفتيش قاد الى العثور على وثيقتين على
الاقل تحمل تصنيف سري داخل صندوق مغلقه في
موقع تخزين تديره الحكومه الفيدراليه ماذا
فعل محامي ترامب لاختار وزاره العدل
بشانها عمليات التفتيش شملت منزل الرئيس
السابق في فلوريدا ومنتجع جولف تابع
لترامب بولايه نيوتيرسي اضافه لبرج ترامب
الواقع في نيويورك لتجنب اشكالات قانونيه
ضد الرئيس السابق بحسب محمد
وزاره العدل ابلغوا محامي الرئيس السابق
انهم يعتقدون انه ربما كل لديه المزيد من
المواد السريه التي لم تتم اعادتها
متحدث باسم ترامب قال ان الرئيس السابق
وفريق محاميه يوصلون العمل بشفافيه وتعاون
كامل مع وزاره العدل الامريكيه
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي سبق له تفتيش
منزل الرئيس السابق ترامب في فلوريدا في
الثامن من اغسطس بحثا عن وثائق سريه
اضافيه وسجلات رئاسيه اخرى عندما فتش
عناصر الاف بي اي منتجع مالاجو عثروا على
وثائق سريه تبتسم بحساسيه كبيره لدرجه ان
موظفي مكافحه التجسس التابعين للمكتب
ومحامي وزاره العدل احتاجه الى التصاريح
اضافيه قبل ان يسمح لهم بالاطلاعي على
وثائق محدده نيورك تايمز قالت انه بينما
تستمر وزاره العدل في طرح اسئله حول
المستندات المفقوده حتى الان
نقل مصدر في الوزاره انه لا يوجد حاليا
سبب محتمل قد يدفع مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي للحصول على امر قضائي لتفتيش
مقرات اخرى لترام اصل الحكايه يرجع الى
سؤال الارشيف الوطني المتكرر خلال العام
الماضي عن بعض المواد التي كان يجب ان
ترسل للمقر الذي يحتفظ بالوثائق الرئاسيه
الا ان المستشار ترامب اكدوا ان الصناديق
المنقوله من البيت الابيض مليئه باغراض
شخصيه فيما اوضح مسؤول الارشيف الوطني ان
قصاصات الصحف يمكن اعتبارها سجلات رئاسي
[موسيقى]
باب التوازي مع تحقيق وزاره العدل تجري
لجنه في الكونجرس تحقيقا موازيا بشان
الوثائق السريه بحوزه ترامب بحلول الثالث
من يناير سيستلم الجمهوريون تفدا مجلس
النواب باغلبيه ضئيله وستكون مسيطره على
لجان الكونغرس على اختلافها النائب جيمس
كومير الذي من المحتمل ان يكون الرئيس
القادم للجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب قال
لسان ان التحقيق في الوثائق السريه لن
يكون هذا اولويه في الكونجرس الجديده
محللون قالوا ان اللجنه القضائيه في مجلس
النواب تحت القياده الجمهوريه ستصوب
سهامها باتجاه وزاره العدل وستعمل اللجنه
كفريق دفاعا عن ترامب اضافه التحليل لان
حلفاء ترامب ستتهمون وزاره العدل باضطهاد
ترامب بشكل غير عادي بينما تتغاضى عن
التحقيق بشان عائله
وتحديدا لاجله هانتر وبحس توقعات سيطالب
الجمهوريون بالوفائق والمصادر الداخليه في
كل حاله تتابعها وزاره العدل بشان ترامب
وهو ما سترفده الوزاره بعدها سيتم اصدار
مذكرات استدعاء للمسؤولين في وزاره العدل
هدف الجمهوريين هنا وفق التحليلات سيكون
تشويه اي قضيه لوزاره العدل ضد ترامب على
ان هذا الدوافع سياسيه وتصفير ترامب على
انه الضحيه لاستنهاض القاعده الجمهوريه
والاهم محاوله شله تحقيقات بشده
[موسيقى]
فروزن
القوات الاسرائيليه ثلاثه فلسطينيين في
جنين واصابه عدد اخر بجروح خلال عمليه
عسكريه زادت من نسبه التوتر المرتفعه اصلا
في اغلب مناطق الدفع الغربيه
ليله صعبه اخرى في جنين القوات
الاسرائيليه تقتحمت المدينه الاعتقال عدد
من المطاردين ولكن قبل ان تصل اليهم كانت
قد قتلت عددا من الشبان احدهم كان في
طريقه الى عمله وفق شهود عيان
كانت اطلاق النار
مشاهد الوداع هذه تكررت في جنين 58 مره
منذ بدايه العام المدينه التي اتسمت بشكل
المسلح للمقاومه دفعت النصيب الاكبر من
الضحايا حيث تؤكد الاحصاءات ان هذا العام
كان الاكثر دمويه على الفلسطينيين منذ
العام 2006
[موسيقى]
وتتضرع اسرائيل في عملياتها داخل المدن
الفلسطينيه بانها تلاحق مطلوبيننا ومنفذين
محتملين لعمليات ضد اهداف لها في الضفه
والداخل
مواكب التشييع المتواصله سواء في جنين او
هنا في رام الله وغيرها من المدن
الفلسطينيه تصب زيت الغضب على نار التصعيد
دون ان تستبعد اسرائيل ان يكون الانفجار
هناك في الجنوب مع قطع غزه من بلده سلواد
عبد الحفيظ جوان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
الافوكادو وراسها اهم فاكهه عند العرب هذه
الايام تابعونا بعد
[موسيقى]
الفرصه
تصريح اليوم مشاهدينا نشعر بالفزع من
اعدام متظاهر ايراني بعد خدوعه لمحاكمه
صوريا تصريح هو لمنظمه العفو الدوليه بعد
اعدام المواطن المحسن شكري لدعوه طعنه
لاحد عناصر الامن المنظمه تعتبرت ان
الاعدام يفضحوا عدم انسانيه النظام
القضائي في ايران لكن يبدو ان بيان منظمه
العفو الدوليه قد يتكرر مئات المرات لان
هذا العدد يواجه المصير ذاته احكام العذاب
فيديو اليوم لامراه تشتكي من مخاد الحمله
وهي علمتني طائره متجهه من المغرب الى
تركيا ما اجبرت طاقم على هبوط اضطراري في
برشلونه هنا كانت المفاجاه
28 شخصا بمن فيهم المراه الحامل اطلقوا
سيقانهم للرياح في المطار الاسبانيه اذا
كانت خطه مدبره في الهروب والبقاء في
اسبانيا وبعد مطارده نجحت الشرطه في توقيف
المراه الحامل واغلب الهاربين كانت الخطه
رائعه حتى الهبوط لكن اين ستختفي في مدارس
المطار
اما صوره اليوم قبل فتره ليست بالقصيره
اطلق عليه احد المعلقين لقب راس الافوكادو
للسخريه منه هو من امكانياته ارتبط الوصف
به لكنها سرعان ما تحول الان الى مدح وليس
ذنب راس الافوكادو هذا يبحث عنه المغاربه
والعرب في كل مكان الان يبحثون عنها ليس
لاكلها ولكن لتقبيلها وليد الرجراجي